let's take a few more calls at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 why don't we try the 5 7 1 area
code and see where that gets us caller
what's your name and where you're
calling from how you doing
so let's let's uh we can barely hear you
you're sort of coming in and out there's
background noise in a very very low
level for your voice let's try one more
time I'm doing my best to hear you my
name is Grover how you doing David
Grover what's on your mind what's going
on colors I'm we're good cool well my
charges um I just bought one on your
coffee to support yeah this is a joke of
course that Gail ever again that do it
is actually your coffee's really good
thank you thank you very little of the
[ __ ] yes actually my co-workers love it
you know the question that I have is
what are you thinking will be the best
armed solution for all these terrorism
that is happening right now even though
in not of course that Islam Saudi Arabia
fool like yeah pretty much
ideology listen it's it's very difficult
to say I mean we we sort of know the
things that haven't worked right
continuing this friendship with Saudi
Arabia where we look the other way as
they fund Wahhabist inspired mosques all
over the West other centers of
radicalization that's not going to work
bulk NSA surveillance we've tried that
we know that it hasn't worked right it
simply has not been effective I know
that this is sort of cliche at this
point but we have to get to the root of
the radicalization and there are those
who say the root of the radicalization
is simply American foreign policy and I
think that that is a black and white
view that is not supported by the facts
there are those who say the basis is
merely Islam and while clearly there is
no doubt that Islam is playing a role in
what is going on you're going to be more
willing to commit a suicide bombing if
you literally believe that once you kill
yourself there will be 72 virgins
waiting awaiting you in heaven right
that's just sort of a practical reality
but that alone is not to blame others
will say well we've got to be focusing
on the mic
of security where and how our security
of perimeters established around
concerts or areas of public transit or
whatever the case may be and there's
probably something to the practicalities
of that but that is not in and of itself
the solution because as we know there
are ways without going into those areas
that you can still cause a lot of terror
so I don't think there is like a single
shot answer Pat you're not going to
adopt the Teresa my approach which is
just to regulate the free and open
Internet regulate the internet-based
yeah I mean the harbor to Pat's point
Grover what Theresa May said after the
London attacks we need to regulate the
Internet what I'm reading into that is
you will not be safe until we are able
to review every single email text
message and phone call that people are
doing and we know that that doesn't work
and it's a practical impossibility so I
I wish I knew more what would work but
we certainly have some idea Grover of
what hasn't worked yeah I understand
that you know I hope everything goes
better for everyone important and
especially for you show that you
suffering up on YouTube for us too so
that's what about you castle yeah thanks
for answering my question thanks so much
Grover all always great to hear from
Grover and yes indeed david pakman show
coffee is available at david pakman.com
slash gear it is a really really great
thing and I encourage you to check it
out and it is one of the many ways that
you can support the work that we do that
is it for today we will take calls again
next week back after this